my name is Kevin Pietersen my films
called the super holidays my website is
for Maj pictures Capcom fr om a GE e AI
si tu re s
why did you make your film I made the
film as a passion project so my
background actually is not in animation
it's in comedy right so it was just a
simply decided to technical originally
as a 30 minute piece we had to keep
scaling back as a budget Shannon
everything seven minutes and during the
whole process was there ever a point
that she wanted to give up there's a lot
of audience or you want to give up i
think is it was a lot of work it took us
two years to make seven minutes of film
so but i think the hardest point was
after we completed animation finally
we'd run out of money and we still
needed to mix all the sound and the
music we sport it with a musician so
that was kind of like the crucial
turning point where we finally yeah
where we had a really dig in and and how
did you go about raising that money than
talked about what we were fortunate
enough to get intel behind us so we got
a sponsorship life from Intel which
which helped push the film we raised
money through his family and friends and
some other corporate sponsors and were
able to get School of Rock involved to
write our theme song so that was very
cool so we became the first words we're
thinking the first animated film dubbed
the theme song actually written my
children are close angle